if you are living a generous other
regarding altruistic life if you're
volunteering formally or just being
helpful informally are there benefits to
that and yes our research has shown that
the benefits are significant so for
example in in one national survey
Americans were asked if they volunteered
in 2009 this was a study that began in
2010 so it was looking back a year
forty-one percent of Americans had
volunteered an average of about a
hundred hours a year which is only two
hours a week roughly so not high
thresholds and then we asked well did it
make you feel physically healthier
sixty-eight percent said yes that's kind
of like getting off carbo's for a little
bit and you know feeling more energized
did it make you feel happy or 96 percent
yes did it make you feel less stressed
seventy-seven percent yes people develop
deeper friendships more meaningful
relationships they had a sense of
gratification they expressed greater
resiliency when they experienced
problems and and tough times in life so
in my view if you could take those kinds
of self-reported benefits and put them
in a in a pill and market them at the
drugstore you'd be a billionaire
overnight but the thing is that you
don't really have to do that because if
people simply get in touch with that
evolved aspect of their of their being
they tend to benefit from it so I was
asked to give a talk at a group of
widows and widowers there's an
association on long island of widows and
widowers and and they wanted to know if
the studies showing that it really helps
with getting through grief and
bereavement if you're if you're able to
report informal helping activities in
your environment gave a really nice talk
and lo and behold at the end in the Q&A
there was a guy in the back and he
looked at me and he said I don't care
what you say buddy I don't do nothing
for nothing
and and you know there is that mentality
that somehow you have to get reciprocal
gains for everything you do it's all tit
for tat but if you look at the science
there are lots of mental and physical
benefits we study a a a lot we study the
12th step which is where people in
Alcoholics Anonymous
help other alcoholics we discovered that
if you have the high quartile of helpers
over that first year of sobriety 40% of
them stay sober for a whole year if you
have the lower quartile of helpers only
22% stay sober so high helping activity
in AAA where you're a greeter at the
door or you're handing out literature or
giving testimony or just meeting other
people in the community who you think
might need a little AAA support or
something like that or being a sponsor
that actually doubles the likelihood of
your recovery within a one-year period
there are a lot of studies like this now
young people adolescents who are engaged
in volunteering show a lower risk for
cardiovascular disease lifelong they
have lower cholesterol levels lower
stress levels there are a whole lot of
things I could talk about there but in
general it's good to be good and science
says it's so-so
I think that's been well established and
a lot of people jumped on that bandwagon
we were probably the first ones to start
working seriously on that or at least
among the first there were other groups
but we funded a lot of research in that
area
published a lot of important things and
now you know it's pretty much the kind
of story that you'd find in Parade
magazine I quote given glow or sometimes
the givers glow all right you know Oh
magazine did a their Christmas article
cover piece on the givers glow this this
past year so it's caught on in the
popular culture but it's not a direct
motivation it's a side effect or a
byproduct and I always like to emphasize
that you're helping others because it's
it's the good thing to do you know it's
the golden rule and all of that but as
it turns
in general it's a very healthy way to go